si se resuelve la desigualdad para ser
gráfica la solución tenemos menos 5
menor o igual que 15 lo voy a escribir
acá un poco más grande y si queremos
resolver esta desigualdad para hacer
simplemente tenemos que aislar a la c
ajá en este momento tenemos que está
siendo multiplicada por este menos 5 y
la mejor manera de tener la cee en el
lado izquierdo a ella sola es
multiplicando a ambos lados de la
desigualdad por el inverso
multiplicativo de menos 5 eso es menos
un quinto entonces multiplicamos menos
un quinto por menos 50 y menos un quinto
por 15 15 por menos un quinto
simplemente estoy multiplicando aquí por
el inverso multiplicativo de menos 5 y
de esta manera al multiplicarlo nos
queda la sola ahora bien aquí no dibuje
el signo de menor o igual porque debemos
recordar que si estamos multiplicando
dividiendo a ambos lados de una
desigualdad por un número negativo
debes voltear el signo de desigualdad y
es justo lo que estoy haciendo aquí
porque estamos aquí multiplicando por
este menos un quinto
es lo mismo que dividir por menos 5
entonces este menor o igual se convierte
a un mayor o igual y ya resolvemos la
desigualdad para hacer tenemos menos un
quinto x menos 5 eso es igual a 1 así
que el lado izquierdo nos queda
simplemente c es mayor o igual que 15 x
menos un quinto es lo mismo que 15 /
menos 5 eso es igual a menos 3 así que
la solución es mayor o igual que menos 3
y ahora graphic hemos esto graphic hemos
la solución voy a dibujar aquí una recta
numérica aquí voy a poner al cero al
menos uno menos dos y menos tres y de
este lado voy a poner al 1 y al 2
entonces se es mayor o igual que menos 3
así que nos dice que puede ser el menos
3 voy a llenar ese espacio y como es
mayor o igual que menos 3 es todo esto
también todo todo esto va a seguir hasta
infinito así que todo lo que sea mayor a
menos 3 eso va a funcionar de hecho
puedes verificarlo escoge
escoger un número que funcione por
ejemplo el 0 deberá funcionar
verifiquemos eso menos 5 por 0 es igual
a 0 y 0 es menor o igual que 15 y de
hecho es menor que 15 entonces si
funciona ahora intentémoslo con un
número que está fuera de la solución
entonces menos 4 por 5 eso es igual a 20
y 20 no es menor o igual que 15 así que
por eso nos da la solución porque no
funciona a todos los números mayores o
igual que menos 3
eso sí funcionan de hecho puedes
intentarlo con cualquier número mayor o
igual que menos 3 inténtalo y diviértete